tell me about these outfits cuz these
are pretty amazing okay thank you um
poison ivy so like I went for a more
kind of a I said kind of a tribal thing
because it's all well and good loving
plants but you got kicks in but to get a
bit badass yeah definitely I'm lady Loki
from the Thor comic books I thought you
know B I wanted to be low key but I
thought it'd be easier being the female
version rather than trying to because
the the male costume in the films is
good but there's a lot of yeah and I'm
not very good at sewing if it's super
hot as well a lot of leather and heavy
I mean I've met a couple of the ones who
are in the Avengers costume and all of
them it's been like I'm melting in here
it's so hot so tell me about putting
them together because there's lots of
different bits and pieces I mean you got
the hair the crown the IV going on well
like some of it is bought like the base
like the dress I bought and then it's
all about kind of like I've been
customizing it and like I bought the IV
and the these are my own okay but yeah
it's kind of like you take like things
like as a base and then like you add to
it and you build it up to like make the
costume that you want lady Loki's
costume actually started off as one of
the weird morph suits you know the
all-in-one weird things which then got
cut up and it needed the skirt and then
the cloak which is a bit of a bother
because people keep standing on it and
then making the horns which are toilet
roll and Mod Rock
yeah and just finding a way to keep them
on my head how have you kept them on
your head
it's bootlaces I've got like tied into
the side and they they hold it on my
head I have ended up like hugging other
Loki's and getting locked and just
adhere like right who's whose horn is
doing what we need we need to
disentangle this is not good if you had
any pitfalls like like lady Loki tag
with being poison ivy any interlocking
dreads releve no thankfully not yet
I have lost a couple of leaves they've
wandered off no mostly my problem is I
stand on my own dress no and in any way
if anyone came in to bother with me I
just have to flirt with them and then
kill them what's your favorite thing
about events like this it's this many
people like her dress up and like cuz
we're all here for the same thing it's
like we all love these films in these
comics and like we're all really excited
about being able to dress up as the
characters and it's like it's great when
you get recognized although if you stop
for five minutes cameras everywhere
cameras everywhere what do you think of
Avengers and also you looking forward to
Thor - I love The Avengers we saw it at
the premiere at the premiere we've seen
it yeah about well I went five times to
the cinema to see it through many times
but it was just it was so exciting
because it's all the characters you love
in one film which I think just makes it
even better in Thor - I'm just really
interested to see where they take Loki's
storyline from there and like how they
deal with everything that happen in the
Avengers and all the issues and it's
exciting it's not it's not till 2013
it's gonna kill me I'm just like I'll
wait here I'll wait here
do you keep in costume the whole time
horns are ready waiting for it to happen
one maybe if I stand here it'll come
quicker guys with that thought keep it
going you're looking fab enjoy the rest
of the weekend and thanks for talking to
you